heard you're having money problems no
you didn't listen I got the answer you
declare bankruptcy all your problems go
away
Creed Bratton has never declared
bankruptcy when creed bratton gets in
trouble he transfers his debt to William
Charles Neider how would that help Creed
in monopoly you go bankrupt you lose you
don't go by monopoly man that game is
nuts nobody just picks up
get-out-of-jail-free cards those things
cost thousands that is a good point
bankruptcy Michael is nature's do-over
it's a fresh start it's a clean slate
like the witness protection program
exotically
I declare bankruptcy
Oh judgment is nigh but that bench
Nikolas ties yes he is finally nigh I am
nine every year my grandfather would
dress up his Belsnickel at Christmas he
was okay at it I am great you know they
say some people were born to be bad
while I was born to be Belsnickel oh
I've traveled from distant lands to
discover how all the boys and the girls
have been behaving this last year Oh too
much strudel so he's kind of like Santa
except dirty and worse no much better no
one here Santa the way they feel best
really
it wasn't me I'm not going down for this
yeah I want to go home get the keys out
of my purse start the car
you're taken - yeah um but one of the
mr. Toby yeah why don't you send that to
him in Costa Rica um I'm just gonna hand
it to him right now okay weirdo why is
that why is that weird she said she was
gonna give it to him right now she's
probably going to you because they sit
next to each other yeah they used to
Toby works here again Oh can you imagine
oh no I don't know I don't know what you
should probably just meander back there
take a look see he's if he's back
dare I you know what I'm going to for
old times sake
great practical joke Jim let me go to
the annex no God no God please no no no
no in prison you are somebody's [ __ ]
how are you you my friend would be the
belle of the ball
don't drop the soap don't drop the soap
Michael please where did you learn all
of this Internet so not prison and
prison it's 50/50 boat look Prison
stinks is what I'm saying it's not like
you can go home and recharge your
batteries and come back in the morning
and be with your friends having fun in
the office what did you do for the Mike
I stole and I robbed and I kidnapped the
president's son and held him for ransom
that is quite the rap sheet prison Mike
and I never got caught Nina
well prison Mike what was the food like
in prison gruel sandwiches gruel omelets
nothing but gruel plus you can eat your
own hair Wow
Prison sounds horrible yeah yeah well
thank you Andy
thanks Megan what's the very very worst
thing about prison do you encourage the
worst thing about prison was that was
the Dementors they were flying all over
the place and they were scary and then
they come down and they sucked the soul
out of your body and then Hoyt Dementors
like in Harry Potter no up eyeball the
entire time I cannot watch Pixar Michael
yes up this one horse
why I found twins oh my god twins I'm
sorry you understand nice to meet you
aren't they magnificent the men white I
love finding a good set of twins
something is wrong hey hey
you want to go to the beach sure you
want to get high no I think you do mom
stop okay
all right no that's good it's just you
need to push it you know you could go a
little bit further
ah all right okay Kelly how are you
I heard that the longest me Oh welcome
to my convenience store would you like
some cookie Kobe I have some very
delicious cookie cookie only 99 cents
plus tax try my cookie-cookie take my
cookie go time ago King donkey time
alright alright yes that was great
she gets it all wrong we've already
tried that
[Music]
this next award is going out to our own
little Pam Beesly I think we all know
what a war Pam is gonna be getting this
year it is the whitest sneakers award
because she always has the widest tennis
shoes on
[Applause]
[Music]
okay first off my kids because around of
applause for emceeing tonight because so
finally I want to thank God because God
gave me this Dundee and I feel God in
this Chili's tonight right okay nice
everybody enjoying their meal hey babe
yeah how about we take the beer sign
down and tell our guests leave and then
we can discuss it no not I'm gonna leave
it up I think it ties a whole room
together okay Jay thanks hunters very
talented
you know what I think he's that good
least he's an artist BFD I'm a
screenwriter I'm a camera maker but you
know all you do is you get me to try to
work on my rich friends for an
investment opportunity man I would love
to burn your handles you buy it you buy
it
Oh Boober and your are delay by verse
[Music]
family $200 plungers creaking me you
just killed good luck
pay me back on your zero dollars a year
salary plus benefits babe
you